[Musik]
[Applaus]
wenn es bestimmte teile der wirtschaft
gibt die von den einnahmen maßnahmen
gegen das corona virus ganz besonders
gebeutelt sind dann wohl alles was mit
tourismus zu tun hat denn praktisch mit
einem schlag kamen hier ganzen branche
mit abermillionen von arbeitsplätzen zu
erliegen branchen die für viele länder
wie zum beispiel spanien von
essentieller bedeutung sind die umsätze
von hotels restaurants bars und cafés
brachen plötzlich auf praktisch null ein
hinzu kommen all die zweit und dritt
runden effekte dh die folgen für alle
unternehmen und beschäftigten welche die
branche beliefern und der landwirtschaft
über den möglich rainer bis hin zu den
ölkonzernen
dies betrifft kleine server und
gewerbetreibende genauso wie ganze
konzerne hart getroffen waren auch die
giganten der luftfahrt sie leiden unter
der austrocknung des tourismus aber auch
vom weitgehenden zusammenbruch des
geschäftsreiseverkehrs
[Musik]
die luftfahrtbranche macht im
dienstleistungssektor aller oecd-länder
kaum 0 3 prozent der wertschöpfung aus
doch sie bildet einen schlüsselfaktor
für den erhalt von millionen von
arbeitsplätzen und abertausenden von
unternehmen die ihre tätigkeit davon
abhängt dass sich die menschen leicht
auf der ganzen welt bewegen können und
natürlich kann sie ein guter gradmesser
für die entwicklung der gesamten
globalen wirtschaftstätigkeit sein
wie aber geht es diesen sektor wirklich
welche genauen auswirkungen wird die
korona krise auf die luft vorhaben und
wie sehen die zukunftsaussichten dieser
branche aus wie du dir vorstellen kannst
verschlechtert sich die lage der
fluggesellschaften mit jedem monat in
denen die restriktionen andauern corona
die aus fluggesellschaften bereiten sich
auf ihr schlechtestes rekordjahr vor
in diesem video wollen wir daher einen
einblick darin gewähren wie die
unternehmen mit dieser situation umgehen
und wir werden nicht nur einen blick auf
die fluggesellschaften werden sondern
auch auf die großen flugzeughersteller
boeing und airbus
man könnte ja ganz naiv glauben deren
wohlergehen hänge auch direkt von denen
ihrer kunden der fluggesellschaften der
logischerweise müssten die ja ohne
passagiere auch keine neuen flugzeuge
kassen doch trifft diese argumentation
wirklich zu nun das werden wir gleich
sehen
die krise in zahlen
[Musik]
schau dir die folgenden zahlen gut an
denn was er dir heute vor augen führen
wollen ist das wahre bild der größten
krise in der luftfahrt seit ihrem
bestehen eine krise gegen welche die
auswirkungen von nine eleven die eine
kleine verschnaufpause wird jetzt zum
beispiel diese grafik an
sie gibt die zahl der von flightradar24
getränkten flügel in den jahren 2009/10
und 2020 wieder leicht erkennen kannst
sagt dix hat alle flüge zwischen märz
und april 2020 auf etwa ein viertel des
2009er wert ist und auch im laufe des
jahres 2020 konnte kaum die hälfte
dieser verluste wieder aufgeholt werden
all dies führt natürlich die verlusten
in milliardenhöhe zunächst für die
fluggesellschaften und möglicherweise
auch für die flugzeughersteller und
darüber hinaus auch für viele andere
firmen und beschäftigte die mit diesen
zusammen arbeiten von catering
unternehmen über die free shops bis zu
denen die erwähnte ölkonzernen und
szenerien aber konzentrieren uns
zunächst auf die fluggesellschaft
[Musik]
eine kürzlich durchgeführte marcuse der
des internationalen luftverkehrs
verbandes hat versucht die auswirkungen
der pandemie abzuschätzen
es wird erwartet dass die
gesamteinnahmen der branche im jahr 2020
im vergleich zu 2009 10 um 46 prozent
sinken werden den fluggesellschaften
droht ein verlust von 314 milliarden
dollar an ticketeinnahmen wodurch die
hälfte der fluggesellschaften weltweit
akut von der pleite bedroht ist die
fluggesellschaften haben seit januar
2020 ihr sitzplatzangebot und
durchschnittlich 70 prozent gekürzt und
jeden monat über zehn milliarden dollar
an ungedeckten kosten verbrannt dazu die
leasingkosten für flugzeuge wartung
mitarbeitergehälter flughafengebühren
und eine vielzahl anderer fixkosten
welche sie ob sie fliegen oder nicht zu
tragen haben
es wird allgemein erwartet dass ist bis
2021 zu keiner nachhaltigen verbesserung
der situation kommen wird was bedeutet
dass die fluggesellschaften möglich
weiterhin zwischen fünf und sechs
milliarden dollar verbrannt werden
dies erklärt an den sturz ins bodenlose
den diese grafik veranschaulicht hinzu
kommt dass auch die zweite jahreshälfte
fluggesellschaften üblicherweise die
profitabelste von restriktionen
dominiert sein wird und es geht nicht um
den drastischen ausfall der einnahmen
denn neben dem enormen rückgang der
nachfrage flügen kommt noch all die
zusätzlichen kosten welche die pandemie
mit sich bringt diese werden noch für
sehr sehr lange zeit eine schwere
belastung des flugverkehrs darstellen
wenn nicht sogar für immer denn die
luftfahrt leidet schon lange darunter
dass die immer mehr und mehr
sicherheitsmaßnahmen einführen muss
diese jedoch nie wieder zurück genommen
werden selbst wenn sie dem
ursprünglichen sinne nicht mehr erfüllen
beispiele dafür sind die beschränkung
von flüssigkeiten auf 100 milliliter und
das handyverbot während start und
landung
bisher ist noch kein einziges flugzeug
wegen eines eingeschalteten handys
abgestürzt und auch flugingenieure
kunden keinerlei interferenzen mit der
flugzeug elektronik im labor nachweisen
außerdem bleibt wohl auch dieses verbot
vermag so wird das fliegen durch immer
mehr rudimentäre und gleichzeitig
reversible maßnahmen belastet und zu all
diesen gesetzlich nun auch all der
aufwand den fluggesellschaften durch die
hygieneregeln und die extra gründliche
reinigung und desinfektion von
flugzeugen entsteht dadurch verlängert
sich auch der aufenthalt der flugzeuge
am boden ihre auslastung durch das
fliegen ansicht sinkt noch mehr die
fluggäste müssen sagt euch natürlich
auch mehr zeit am boden verbringen was
dazu führt dass die flugverbindungen
zwischen den flügen nicht mehr so kurz
sind wie früher
all das ist nicht nur eine große
herausforderung für die flugplanung st
denn was fluggesellschaften ganz
besonders heißen sind flugzeuge die sich
nicht in der luft befinden denn jedes
flugzeug das am boden herum steht kostet
geld verdient aber kein ist
[Musik]
darüber hinaus müssen die besatzungen
jetzt auch selbst filtern die maske und
in vielen fällen schutzbrillen und sogar
sogenannte apps also vollständige
persönliche medizinische
schutzausrüstung tragen so wie es bei
vielen asiatischen fluggesellschaften
beispielsweise ja kommen er und den
meisten chinesischen fluggesellschaften
bereits der fall ist die zahl der für
die fluggesellschaften belastenden
faktoren ist so groß dass wir die in
diesem video wirklich nur ein bruchteil
davon darstellen können was aber auch so
jedem klar sein sollte ist die tatsache
dass viele unternehmen auf der ganzen
welt deswegen an den rand des bankrotts
geraten sind nur mit hilfe von staatlich
gewährten schuldenmoratorium oder
subventionen dahinvegetieren oder
einfach schon konkurs angemeldet haben
insgesamt könnte der schaden den des
corona virus in der luftfahrtindustrie
anrichtet in vielerlei hinsicht und
viele jahre er reparabel sein doch
welche auswirkungen werden diese schäden
auf den verbraucher die passagiere haben
wird die ära der billigflüge an die sich
viele so sehr gewöhnt haben damit zu
ende gehen das schauen wir uns jetzt mal
etwas genauer an
wege zur rettung
[Musik]
da fast zwei drittel der weltweit 26.000
passagierflugzeuge am boden stehen und
rund 25 millionen arbeitsplätze
gefährdet sind steht die
fluggesellschaft und im jahr 2020 vor
einem großen dilemma sie müssen wege
finden um ihre vollkommene liquidierung
zu vermeiden auch wenn sie dafür auf
verschiedene kniffe des konkursrechts
und staatliche rettungsmechanismen
zurückgreifen müssen welcher liste die
von land zu land mal besser oder
schlechter funktionieren wenn wir zum
beispiel die entwicklung der
fluggesellschaften in den ersten monaten
des jahres 2020 und ihr finanzielles
risiko betrachten sehen wir ein muster
das ost asien zugute kommt und
insbesondere afrika und lateinamerika
schadet in lateinamerika wussten die
kolumbianische avianca aero mexico die
chilenische lan und tam aus ecuador
bereits in den usa konkurs anmelden
in afrika stecken die fluggesellschaften
wies auf african airways und air
marshals in der pleite und auch wenn ein
konkurs nicht notwendigerweise die
auflösung des ganzen unternehmens nach
sich zieht so läuft ist doch meistens
auf zwei arten von lösungen hinaus
entweder die liquidation der aktiver und
das verschwinden des unternehmens oder
die finanzielle umstrukturierung der
schulden die bereitstellung staatlicher
hilfsgelder und falls erforderlich das
ersetzen der vorherigen anteilseigner
bzw
die verwässerung ihrer anteile
[Musik]
[Applaus]
genau dies wird in naher zukunft zu
drastischen unterschiede zwischen
verschiedenen regionen der welt führen
denn es gibt nur extrem wenige
fluggesellschaften die in der lage sein
werden ohne staatliche hilfen in form
von subventionen investitionen oder
darlehen aus dieser misere wieder
herauszukommen
[Musik]
denn ein ungeordnetes kokos verfahren
ohne staatliche eingriffe wird sehr
viele risiken viele regierungen und
haben bei der finanziellen unterstützung
von arbeitsplätzen in der luftfahrt gute
arbeit geleistet
wo dies nicht geschehen ist zum beispiel
in lateinamerika sehen wir konkurse die
fluggesellschaften verbrennen weiterhin
geld und es wird erwartet dass dies bis
ins nächste jahr andauern wird ohne als
zweite tranche von finanzhilfen damit
viele fluggesellschaften den winter
nicht überleben alexandre de juniac
generaldirektor des internationalen
luftverkehrs verbandes
wie so oft bilden aber auch hier weit
die allerbesten vorsätze der staaten
einen ausgezeichneten bodenbelag mit dem
sie wege in die hölle cluster lassen
dabei geht es nicht nur darum dass wir
steuerzahler am ende wieder einmal die
zeche für die entscheidungen unserer
politiker zahlen müssen sondern auch um
den rückfall in eine katastrophale
verstaatlichungspolitik wenn wir nämlich
einen blick in die geschichte der
luftfahrt industrie werfen stellte er
fest dass diese quasi schon immer ein
reines verlust oder zuschussgeschäft war
die kommerzielle luftfahrt gibt es seit
dem jahr 1914 und erst vor kurzem haben
es die globalen airlines mit mühe und
not geschafft unterm strich eine
schwarze null zu produzieren und jetzt
fragst du dich sicher
wieso so viele menschen und investoren
mehr als 100 jahre lang nur geld in die
unternehmen dieser branchen gebuttert
haben bis mal ein cent gewinn
herausgesprungen ist nun einer der
hauptgründe war dass viele
fluggesellschaften jahrzehntelang stars
unternehmen waren fast jeder staat hielt
sich aus prestige konnten eine eigene
fluggesellschaft um zum beispiel
flugrouten am leben zu erhalten
die eigentlich gar nicht profitabel
waren diese staatswirtschaft waren
natürlich lange zeit tores gerichts für
den wettbewerb und dies wiederum ein
perfekter nährboden für ineffiziente
unternehmensstrukturen korruption und
schlendrian das fliegen war deswegen
lange zeit sowohl für den fluggast eine
sehr teure angelegenheit als auch für
den steuerzahler erst in den 1990 er
jahren will kann eine allmähliche
besserung dieser zustände durch private
airline kosten und angebots modell der
privatisierung staatlicher fluglinien
und der allgemeinen deregulierung des
marktes durch dieses mehr an
marktwirtschaft wurde fliegen wesentlich
günstiger und für die breiten massen
erschwinglich und die fluggesellschaften
wurden im vergangenen jahrzehnt endlich
über 100 jahren unterm strich profitabel
ja das alles ist jetzt aber auch
geschichte in ihrer gut müssen die
unternehmen geradezu darum betteln
wieder vom staat abhängig zu werden
in vielen fällen geht es nicht darum
dass ein unternehmen aus eigener schuld
in schieflage gerät sondern dass die von
den regierungen auferlegten
gesundheitspolitischen maßnahmen die
abriegelung charakteren ausgangssperren
auch teilschließungen und andere
maßnahmen zur bekämpfung der pandemie
direkt das geschäft der
fluggesellschaften angreifen welches
hauptsächlich von der beförderung von
touristen und geschäftsleute abhängt mit
anderen worten es geht nicht darum dass
das eine oder andere unternehmen
schlecht abgeschnitten
und wegen schlechten managements
untergegangen ist dies eine ganz
besondere situation die nur ganz wenige
unternehmen in diesem sektor egal wie
viel geld und ersparnisse sie noch haben
aus eigener kraft tragen können fast
alle einnahmequellen fluggesellschaften
versiegen
während ihre ausgaben weiter laufen
der charakter dieser staatlichen
rettungsaktion fällt jedoch von fall zu
fall sehr unterschiedlich aus es macht
einen großen unterschied ob es reine
subventionen sind die nicht
zurückgezahlt werden müssen darlehen zu
vorzugsbedingungen oder gar
kapitalbeteiligungen die deutsche
lufthansa erhielt zum beispiel aus
deutschland belgien österreich und der
schweiz insgesamt neun milliarden euro
an staatshilfen
überwiegend in form von krediten zu
sonderkonditionen trotz aller warnungen
bestand die bundesregierung jedoch auf
einer beteiligung als voraussetzung für
dieses paket im zuge der finanzpresse
soll der bund einen anteil von 20% zu
einem vorzugspreis von 2 eur 56 pro
aktie übernehmen
an der börse wurde eine lufthansa-aktie
damals für circa 10 euro gehandelt
und trotzdem stimmten die altaktionäre
diesen deal zu
tatsache ist jedoch dass die
fluggesellschaften weltweit allein in
den ersten sechs monaten des jahres 2020
162 milliarden dollar an staatlichen
beihilfen erhalten haben und von dieser
innovation mit bereits rund 80 prozent
aufgebraucht haben und du kannst ja
sicher denken dass noch sehr viel mehr
geld benötigt wird wenn wir bedenken
dass der flugverkehr voraussichtlich
erst im jahr 2040 wieder auf das niveau
von 2009/10 zurück geändert aber die
frage ist das wird außerdem trotz der
öffentlichen geldern noch getan also
schonmal cathay pacific schließt
regionale tochtergesellschaft und
streicht 8000 500 arbeitsplätze
chorin erkauft asiana und steigt zur
zehn größten fluggesellschaft der welt
auf chinas führende fluggesellschaft
kehrt mit dem aufblühen der
inlandsrouten in die gewinnzone zurück
ich hatte hier wo ich mal einen moment
inne um über diese drei verschiedene
schlagzeilen nachzudenken sie könnten
ein spiegelbild dessen sein wie der
luftverkehr in den nächsten jahren
aussehen wird eine verringerung des
angebots und eine ausdünnung des
frequenzen verfügen
die zahl der beschäftigten in der
branche wird dadurch drastisch sinken
tochtergesellschaft und werden
eliminiert insbesondere low cost
airlines eine zentralisierung in die
muttergesellschaft unter stattfinden es
wird zusammenschlüsse von unternehmen
zur schaffung größerer und stärkere
einheiten geben was den wettbewerb und
in krieg und niedrige preise stark
einschränken wird und schließlich eine
verlagerung auf den chinesischen markt
insbesondere für flugzeughersteller vor
allem letzteres könnte sich als
schlüssel für die zukunft mit boeing und
airbus erweisen
die in den letzten monaten einen
rückgang ihrer bestellungen und ein
riesige zahl von stornierungen bereits
bestellter flugzeuge verzeichnen mussten
diese beiden weltgrößten
flugzeughersteller boeing und airbus
sind das nächste glied in dieser krisen
kette die frage lautet also welche
zukunft erwartet die beiden führenden
flugzeughersteller der welt
[Musik]
hofft jemand mal eine flugzeuge
wir wissen nicht ob die angst vor einer
globalen pandemie den managern von wohin
und er war es schon vor 2020 schlaflose
nächte bereitet hat was wir aber wissen
ist dass die boeing co waren sicherlich
auch schon vorher gute kunden der
schleifmittelhersteller waren da wäre
zum einen das dritte modell 737 max die
mängel bei der 787 und die verzögerung
bei der markteinführung der 777 x-men
boeing leidet schon seit längerem unter
missmanagement fehlentscheidungen und
einem verfall der firmenkultur
genauer gesagt ist dies seit der
übernahme von madness der fall denn
obwohl bohinc der größere partner dieser
fusion war schaffte es die ehemalige
führungsriege von mcdonnell douglas des
zu recht erfolglose rinn uns daher
verschlucken unternehmens mit hilfe von
politik und intrigen im laufe der jahre
die führung eine spitze des neuen gesamt
kunstherz übernehmen und zwar mit
fatalen folgen für die führungs und
unternehmenskultur eine führungskultur
die nun wohl kaum in der lage ist die
folgen der krise abzufedern
er leitete zweiten monat in folge ohne
bestellungen von fluggesellschaften
übrigens ein vorkommnis wie es seit 1962
nicht mehr geschehen war
du kannst er sich gut vorstellen was da
eine katastrophe es für einen solch
großen konzern darstellt zwei monate
lang nichts aber auch rein gar nichts zu
verkaufen für ein unternehmen wie boeing
das bereits 2019 stark gelitten hat und
so mehr
[Musik]
bis zum dritten quartal 2020 hat wohin
verluste in höhe von 3,5 4 6 milliarden
dollar verzeichnet nachdem für das jahr
2009 10 ein gewinn von nur 444 millionen
dollar verzeichnet worden war
was bereits einen gewaltigen eindruck
von den 83 5 milliarden dollar gewinn
des jahres 2018 darstellt darüber hinaus
hat die schwierige lage der
fluggesellschaften zu stornierungen von
flugzeugbestellungen geführt wo hin zum
beispiel verzeichnet bereits einen
nettoverlust von 1020 bestellungen und
hat bis oktober 2020 nur ganze 67
flugzeuge verkauft zudem gelang boeing
in diesem zeitraum nur die auslieferung
von 111 flugzeuge
gegenüber 341 im vorjahreszeitraum
[Musik]
angesichts dieser ergebnisse ist es
nicht überraschend dass wohin weltweit
mehr als 30.000 beschäftigte entlassen
wird fast 20 prozent der gesamten
belegschaft weil airbus hingegen scheint
etwas besser zu laufen und das
unternehmen wird aus der krise hat die
zu boeing in einer stärkeren position
hervorgehen er was konnte seine zahlen
auch dadurch retten
dass einige fluggesellschaften nachdem
737 max fiasko boeing den rücken kehrten
und zu airbus überließen
[Musik]
zwischen januar und oktober hat er bass
413 flugzeuge ausgeliefert bringt nur
111 auf den ersten blick ist das für
erst gar nicht mal schlecht aber im
vergleich zum gleichen zeitraum des
vorjahres ist das auch für airbus ein
eindruck von 234 stück mehr als einem
drittel und natürlich musste er was auch
arbeitsplätze abbauen angekündigt wurde
ein weltweiter abbau von 15.000 stellen
das sind elf prozent der belegschaft
die flugzeughersteller dürften sich
dennoch viel stärker erholen als die
fluggesellschaften zumal als länder wie
china gibt in denen die nachfrage nach
flugzeugen nicht nur nicht besuchen ist
sollen weiter wächst der asiatische
riese will bis 2039 8600 neue flugzeuge
im wert von etwa 1,4 billionen dollar
kaufen wohin und er was müssen also erst
mal nur die kurz und mittelfristige
durststrecke überwinden um dann
langfristig wieder fürs big business
bereit zu sein
vor allem in asien wohin gewusst die
auswirkungen der 737 max belegung
überwinden und er war seine stars wie
diana 220 fithalten fluggesellschaften
hingegen werden noch viele und tiefe
einschnitte vornehmen müssen
die schuldenberge welche sie nun
auftürmen um ihrer flotten und
arbeitsplätze zu erhalten und die
fixkosten zu decken wären sie für viele
jahre wie bleibt nach unten ziehen die
zahlreichen fusionen und übernahmen
werden nicht nur gewaltige reibereien
durch ihre organisation und kulturelle
interessen hervorrufen sondern vor allem
auch den wettbewerb untergraben und das
werden die kunden die fluggäste sehr
stark zu spüren bekommen die einzige
hoffnung für die fluggesellschaften
besteht heute darin irgendwie wieder
marien aus dem hut zaubern zum beispiel
durch höhere preise und senkung der
kosten indem sie kostenlose service
angebote abschaffen und die passagiere
für noch mehr bezahlen lassen als zuvor
aber was meinst du
wird das corona virus die welt der
luftfahrt wirklich für immer verändern
oder werden wir bald wieder so reisen
wie früher könnte diese pandemie er was
ein für allemal zu führenden
flugzeughersteller der welt machen
schreibt uns einfach alles was ihr
einfällt als kommentar unter dieses
video
denn die inhalte auf diese schon
hochgradig gespannt und ich hoffe dass
er dieses video gefallen und etwas
gebracht hat falls ja gib uns bitte
einen daumen hoch und unterstütze uns
indem du es mit deinen freunden teilt
und vergesst nicht dass für jede woche
neue videos hochladen
abonnieren sie unseren kanal kriegt auch
auf das lebens und wohl um rechtzeitig
benachrichtigt zu werden mach s gut und
bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]